eine aufblasbare raumstation das soll
gehen sie wiegen weniger und haben
deutlich weniger transportvolumen als
gewöhnliche raumstation und das würde
beim raketenstart enorme mengen an geld
sparen
nasa astronautin und astronauten werden
jetzt drei tage lang in solch einer mars
transporter testing unit leben und eine
solche station ist schon im weltraum
einsatz tritt zum science fiction gibt's
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen
die idee stammt von dem
us-amerikanischen mehr der robert
bigelow der mit einer hotelkette großes
geld verdient hat aber ihn zieht es
zudem auch in den weltraum und so hat er
die firma bigelow aerospace gegründet
wie gelobt möchte aufblasbare
raumstationen raumschiffe und mond basen
bauen denn das hätte viele vorteile
gewöhnliche fracht raketen könnten
solche aufblasbaren raumstationen ins
all bringen wo sie dann mit hilfe von
gasflaschen zu ihrer richtigen größe
aufgeblasen werden
klar ist dass dadurch enorm viel geld
gespart werden könnte der normalerweise
müssen raumstationen stück für stück in
den weltraum gebracht werden doch bloß
idee hätte einen weiteren vorteil denn
viele einzelteile bedeuten auch viele
verbindungsstücke zwischen ihn und genau
da schlummern potenzielle schwachstellen
der raumstation die letztendlich auch
die sicherheit der astronauten
astronauten gefährden da bloß
aufblasbare raumstation module aus
wenigen einzelteilen bestehen ist dieses
risiko minimiert robert bigelow will
jetzt auch die nasa von seinem plan
überzeugen
deswegen hat er die sogenannte mars
transportiert esting junis aufgebaut
dabei handelt es sich um einen nachbau
des sogenannten b 330 moduls das
aufgeblasen ein volumen von 330
kubikmetern hat deswegen also auch sein
name bei 330 ist konzipiert als aus tage
weltraumstation in der fünf astronauten
astronauten für einige monate leben
könnten vier menschen an bord könnten ja
ewig oder so lange wie die
weltraumstation existiert darin bleiben
kilos maß transporter testing jugend
allerdings ist zunächst nur einmal ein
nachbau aus metall allerdings auch in
originalgröße 330 kubikmeter
entsprechend übrigens ein drittel des
volumens des es also wirklich ziemlich
groß die testing juni soll jetzt von
nasa fachleuten
gutachten und getestet werden bei den
tests sollen unter anderem einen
astronauten team für drei tage in diesem
modul bleiben doch bigelows modul ist
nicht das einzige was derzeit von der
nasa geprüft wird weitere prototypen von
anderen unternehmen sind auch dabei in
bigelows testing unit jedenfalls wird es
den nasa testern an nichts fehlen sie
besteht aus einem großen frachtraum drei
decks zwei kombüsen zwei toiletten
arbeitsstationen und vorrichtungen die
für die pflanzenzucht gedacht sind der
test der nase läuft nicht zum spaß sie
sind teil des sogenannten next step
programms next step technologies for
exploration partnerships die besten
projekte können am ende auf förderung
der nasa hoffen im besten fall könnten
die prototypen dann sogar zu einer
weltraumstation für den mond orbit
weiterentwickelt werden bei der nächsten
bemannte mondmissionen artemis im jahr
2024 könnte diese weltraumstation dann
eine entscheidende rolle spielen es geht
um den space gateway also ein
außenposten der menschheit im all
vergleichbar media ss diese station soll
den mond umkreisen und robotern und
astronauten themen ist als basis zur
erforschung der mondoberfläche dient
doch das gateway könnte auch als
zwischenstopp dienen wenn astronauten
und astronautinnen in der mondumlaufbahn
pausieren wollen bigelow ist aber selbst
das nicht genug seine vision sind in
grosser b 330 könnte seiner vorstellung
auch als habitat auf der mondoberfläche
selbst dienen doch nicht nur der mond
sondern auch der mars kommt bloß
vorstellungen zum folge als ziel in
frage bei 330 könnte demnach also teil
eines raumschiffes sein das zum mars
fliegt der etwa neun monate langen flug
zum roten planeten könnte die besatzung
in b 330 gut überstehen und an bigelow
modul ist bereits an der iss im einsatz
und hat alle erwartungen ja überall
fühlt muss man sagen das expandable
aktive die mode und ihm wurde am 8 april
2016 an der iss angedockt und im
anschluss aufgeblasen eigentlich sollte
es nur auf dichtigkeit getestet werden
und dann abgekoppelt werden und in der
erdatmosphäre verglühen
die nasa hatte offenbar kein so
richtiges vertrauen in die konstruktion
doch die den dichtigkeit test hat es zur
vollsten zufriedenheit absolviert bisher
gibt es noch keine einzige undichtigkeit
alles funktioniert tadellos und deswegen
wurde es inzwischen von der nasa bis zum
jahr 2028 für die iss
infiziert und nicht nur das das modul
wurde umgebaut und wird inzwischen als
lagerraum genutzt wo kann man im
weltraum gemüse züchten anklicken also
hier anschauen und astro comics tv
abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran